- Marcia said that she was who she was
and her motto was, "I'm me, I'm here,
"and you all better get your life."
(jazzy music)
- A lot of people that comment on Basquiat
say that the pieces are
like, a child could draw that
and they're not painted by
someone who's an artist,
but he's an extremely talented painter.
Although the drawings look simple,
they were extremely complex.
They usually talked about social
issues, social commentary.
They dealt with things such as racism,
economic equality, and all
these things in the nation.
As an artist, he's influenced me
because he was someone
that was very brash.
His look was very
uncaring, but it was helm.
And that's something
that's been influencing me,
especially with growing out my hair.
I saw him as someone who
was extremely comfortable
in who he was and the way that he looked
was exactly how he wanted to look.
For as long as he lived,
that's how society thought
that a black man's hair should be.
At that time, (mumbling)
wearing these clothes.
Looking at the photo while
I was trying to do it
was really hard, and then
to see the finished product
was like, "Oh, I accomplished it."
It was really cool to see.
It looked like who I look up to.
It was a really good feeling.
- There was the Civil Rights
movement, and then Malcolm X.
I think a lot of people
misinterpreted him.
A lot of people consider him
to be the one who was like,
"No, there needs to be violence,"
when actually, he was the one saying,
"No, there needs to be
peaceful protesting,
"but black people also need to learn
"how to defend themselves."
He was just very realistic,
very unapologetic.
With segregation, when
segregation was happening,
he was also very much like,
"No, okay, this is happening,
"but we need to also
have black organizations.
"We need to organize
black people together.
"If they want segregation, then
we're gonna give it to them
"and prove to them that black people
"can still flourish throughout this time."
Just because the system is against you,
doesn't mean that you have
to be against yourself.
You can still fight and
you can still make it.
That's important, because these
issues that were happening
in the '60s and '70s are
still happening today.
I mean, yes, we have
made a lot of progress,
but there's still a huge
fight that needs to happen.
I was almost moved to tears,
which was really surprising.
I didn't expect to be
so moved to see myself
with a side by side picture of him
and kind of look like him.
It surprised me, I
actually did really well.
- James Baldwin was a writer poet.
He specialized in thinking
and writing and critiquing
on black culture or the black experience.
I think it's important for the world,
and not just Americans
even, the entire world,
because they need to
know that black people,
or people of color artists
are here and existing,
and have something to say, and are valued.
He makes me feel okay that I walk away
for something that feels like a good deal
or feels like a good job
if I'm unhappy with it.
He talks about the good
deal or the good job
as this warm house, and yet
you can't get inside of it
and you don't want to be inside of it.
If you get inside of it, you
will leave after five minutes
because you just have to be
working on your own thing.
It felt great to talk and
take photos and be Baldwin.
I think he was important
to the black community
to know that it's been done for,
and that you can do it again.
- During a time when women were like,
girding their loins and
hiding their bodies,
she was celebrating her
body dancing topless
and had over a thousand
marriage proposals.
Growing up and hearing
about Josephine Baker
and how in control of
her sexuality she was,
it was definitely
something that I looked to
when I became a woman.
During World War II, Josephine
Baker worked with the French
to carry secrets in their sheet music
and was awarded multiple French
medals of honor afterwards.
She came back to the United States
during the Civil Rights movement,
was the only woman to speak
during the 1963 March on Washington.
Not only was she a celebrity,
but she parlayed her celebrity
into major activism and used her power
to the betterment of other people.
- Marsha P. Johnson was a fierce activist
and advocate from the
late '60s and early '70s.
Let me paint you a picture.
It's 1969, you're black, you're a woman,
and you're a member of
the queer community.
She realized that
equality was for everyone,
despite your sexuality, your
orientation or your race.
She was a part of the major
movement in the Stonewall riots
in 1969, and the unfortunate
part is, after all the work
that her and Sylvia Rivera
did for the gay movement,
they actually shunned
her and they despised her
because she didn't fit
into a certain class.
Stonewall was a huge part of the movement
because they weren't afraid.
It was one of the few times in history
where queer, trans, gay, lesbian people
stood together unified
and said that they would
no longer take it and that
they had a right to hold space.
It feels good to know that
the reason why I'm here today
is because of people
like Marsha P. Johnson
and the work that she's done,
so I feel I'm a descendant of greatness.
- It's extremely important
for black children
to see black heroes in their field,
because you wanna believe
that you can achieve success.
You wanna believe that
someone that looks like you,
went through the same thing as you,
had the same struggles as you,
and understands where you're coming from.
A lot of times, you just want to be happy
to know that you can do it.